hi everyone good morning everyone
there you go good morning james
how are you i'm doing very well
and so thank you so much for inviting me
we'll get started in just a moment
uh it's a pleasure to be here at pi data
festival amsterdam
we really wanted to hold an in-person pi
data amsterdam this year
unfortunately we weren't able to go into
the current circumstances
but i'm very glad that mataya through
the hard work of mathias and mauricio
were able to do this event
and so i think even though they can't
hear you hopefully
those of you watching at home and give
them a little round of applause to thank
them for all of their hard work putting
this event on one of the upsides of that
is going to be that of all the pi data
events pi data amsterdam will have
maybe the longest unbroken record of
conferences and so
they will get their kudos in the end now
today i want to present to you a topic
that you may have heard people talk
about a lot
optimization in python how to make
python code fast i gave this talk that's
a very tedious title
fast and furious and fast python 7 just
to reflect on a very tedious
movie series that you've probably seen
before probably fell asleep in
and i'm sure you've had the exact same
experience when watching optimization
talks
in just a moment i'll share my screen
with you and then we'll get started now
just a note this is a talk
and it's a novice level talk and so
unfortunately i don't have much workshop
material i'll just be presenting for you
now you can see my screen behind me in
just a moment i'll
hide in the very corner of the screen
just so you can see everything and we'll
get started
the title of this talk is furious and
fast python 7.
we're at pi data fest amsterdam it's
thursday
june 17th 2020. it's my pleasure to be
here presenting this material to all of
you
now i will note that it is 3am for me in
new york and so
i really must enjoy coming to speak to
with all of you if i'm willing to stay
up this late to
present for you i'm james powell if you
like this talk or you're interested in
similar material you can follow me on
twitter at don't use this code
i give quite a few talks at different pi
data events unfortunately this year we
don't have as many
pi data events but i'll be speaking
again most likely at pi data global
another event that matthias is involved
in later this year
as i said this is a talk not a workshop
and it's novice level so hopefully this
talk might give you a new framework or
new way to think about things
but it may not tell you anything that
you might not have seen before just to
get you ready for
what you're going to see now it is the
case that when we talk about python
everybody wants to write
fast python code it seems so it seems
obvious this is something that you want
to do
and you might you might ask yourself
once why
like why do we care about writing fast
python code is it because it's scalable
i guess that kind of makes sense because
we could say that if we're in a business
context
there's always this competitive push
this capitalistic push to grow
and if our code isn't scalable then it
can't grow and so our business will find
some some business model by which it can
make money it'll try to scale that up
that's nature of what a business is
and so scalability is very closely tied
to that model but
i don't know if that's as compelling
because you can see you know your code
may not be the
factor that actually matters in the
scalability of some system
you could you could say well because
it's performance and i would say this is
a probably a very bad reason because
this word performance just a terrible
word please don't ever use it it's
probably the worst word you could
probably come up with
what does it even mean you could say
maybe one of the reasons why people
really like to make their code fast is
because it's measurable
if i say oh i wrote some code and it's
really easy to read it's not really
measurable
doesn't seem objective but if i say oh
my code runs in three
and your code runs in five well that's
definitely measurable so i think for a
large degree when people talk about
writing fast code it's often just
because this is a measurable
thing that they can do on their code and
there are oftentimes ignoring other more
important factors in terms of
the readability of the code the
extensibility of the code in a moment
we'll talk about one
clear problem when people talk about
code and the speed of code
and we'll see how you know just because
this is a measurable unit
that measures one snapshot on time
doesn't necessarily mean it'll make it a
very good measure
of the overall quality of your code base
now unfortunately
irrespective of the reason why you might
want to make your code fast
python is slow and we're told python is
slow and where
we you know get very excited when we
first learn python and then we realize
oh this is so slow it's so much slower
than all the other tools that i use
but like whatever like seriously
this is just seems to be the complaints
about the speed of python
often seems to be just something that is
very easy to complain about just like
people like to complain about the global
interpreter lock
it seems more of a lightning rod for
complaints than any very serious
substantial
complaint and the reason that i might
say that is if you look at some very
very high performance systems
things like gpt2 they're written using
tensorflow or pi
torch they are written using python
bindings and so you can see things that
are very performance sensitive
still have some element of python to
them and so this idea that python is
slow and that's the end of the story
and you should just go and use something
that's faster seems to be missing
something very significant
now one important question when we talk
about fast code is do you really want to
write fast code or do you want to write
fast enough code i think oftentimes when
people try to aim for performance
what they really want is they want code
that's fast enough to get a certain job
done
there's a hidden bear there's a hidden
bar that they're trying to hit
and past that bar it's not really that
meaningful for them to go any further
and you'll see that when we actually
talk about
typical mechanisms by which our typical
processes by which people
do optimization now one of the problems
that we have when people talk about
optimization is they talk about it as a
static process
but in reality when you're talking about
optimization of real world code
it's really a dynamic process and here
you can see we're leaning into our
static dynamic dichotomy a little bit
hard
but just to break down these terms for
you you might think that if we're
talking about a static process we're
talking about looking at a given piece
of code at a fixed time
and we're trying to make it faster so
we're saying the code as it exists today
let's see if we can iterate on it and
make it faster
whereas the reality of code bases is
that they're part of a dynamic process
in reality we don't want to make the
code faster today
we want to take a given piece of code
and make it faster over time
if our code is fastest today and then
becomes the slowest code tomorrow
that's not desirable for us in a very
similar sense oftentimes when we talk
about design problems or we talk about
the we talk about characteristics of
code bases we're often talking about
them in a snapshot view we're talking
about them statically
we're saying if we take this fixed
problem in space and time
and we try and figure out the best way
to model it what is the best way to
model it but in reality an
actual codebase is part of a dynamic
process it's part of a software
development process
and the software development process is
fundamentally dynamic in other words
you're given a requirement on day one
and you're given many requirements on
day two day three three months later six
months later one year later
similarly your code ex starts with some
smaller
set of cases that it has to solve three
months later six months later a year
later
the number of cases that it has to solve
the size of the data sets it has to
process are very different and the
dynamics of those
may be significantly different as a
consequence things that you might do on
day one
to lead to writing what you think is the
fastest code may not survive
until day 365 or
year day one of year 10 of this code
base
now it is important that we
contextualize this idea of optimization
in the terms of the software development
process we really have to think
how is software actually written and
what we really need to do
to approach this topic better is to come
up with a better framework a better way
to consider
what it means to optimize code what it
means for code to be fast
and so what i've prepared for you in
this talk is a framework
that might help you try to put a little
bit of substance
behind these discussions of optimization
and discussions of how we go about
making a code fast
and i i call this framework the m-i-s-s
a framework the m stands for measurement
the i stands for intuition
the s stands for structure the other s
stands for specialization
and the a stands for acronym and in fact
the
second to last s actually stands for
stupid because this is a very
stupid acronym and in fact it's not even
an acronym it's an initialism
so really this is the m-i-s-s-i
framework now let's start with the first
letter of this framework
measurement it is obviously the case
that if we want to make our code fast we
have to perform some measurement
we have a limited amount of time and in
that limited amount of time we have to
decide
where we're going to spend that time to
change some code in our code base
and so it doesn't make sense for us to
try to micro-optimize every single line
of code
it makes sense for us to measure to use
those measurements to guide ourselves
but that's not
really about the code itself so much is
about our dynamic
in the software development process in
other words it's about we have finite
time and finite resources
and how do we best exploit those finite
resources because
if you did not have finite resources if
you had an infinite number of
programmers working on your code base
there really wouldn't be any value for
measurement you would just try to
optimize
every single aspect of that code now you
may have heard a three-step process
for a software development process that
situates this idea of optimization
near the end you may have heard people
say things like make it work
make it right make it fast in other
words first make the code actually work
make it do something
from a business perspective this is a
good idea you know if the code doesn't
work at all
then it's not really valuable making it
fast if
the code isn't correct then that it's
fast might not be valuable either
and so you first make the code work then
you make sure the code is correct
you make sure the code is giving you the
right results and then you perform
optimizations
this is a framework that you might have
seen in reference to comments about
optimization from folks like dijkstra
dijkstra was famously somewhat uh
bearish on
optimization as in a practice because he
said look if the code is not correct
who cares how fast it is now as in a
business process that's not always
really the case for how we
approach or look at our code instead if
we really think about what we do we
oftentimes
kind of make it sort of work and then we
make it fast and then we sort of check
to see if it's right
and we don't do any of these process
just right so i think that three-step
framework is missing
some realities how we go about writing
code instead
what we might do is we might start with
some measurements and there are many
many measurement tools that we might use
you may be familiar with sampling
measurement tools like pi spy
a very popular one that i've seen that's
led to some very interesting examples
of optimizations is scalene and with
these tools we might make micro
optimizations we measure some code we
identify some hot spot lines we go into
those hot spot lines we make micro
optimizations we rewrite those lines
or some subset of those lines and
improve them but there's a problem with
this process
and a very significant problem because
when we do that we're looking at this
code as a static entity we're not
looking at as a dynamic entity let me
give you
an example fundamentally when we look at
a code base that codebase is subject to
an execution environment that execution
environment may change over time
i'll give you a canonical example i
myself have no software and
no computer science background i have an
electrical engineering background
and i started writing code on
microcontrollers and in microcontrollers
there's a certain fundamental aspect
that doesn't carry
over to the kinds of computers that i
write software for
in other words in microcontrollers there
was a memory versus cpu dichotomy
and every time the code was kind of slow
we leaned on our memory we write lookup
tables
but that approach doesn't work anymore
it doesn't work for our for our standard
mini computers for our desktop computers
and for our servers
now we lean towards the cpu we say you
know what memory access times
are so slow that it's sometimes better
to do redundant computations with cpu
than to pay for a lookup table because
the the
slowness of accessing anything past l1
cache is not worth the time and so you
can see that fundamental dynamic changes
over time
a consequence would be if i in 1992
wrote some code trying to make it the
fastest in the world and i use the
lookup table
come 2004 2005
it's no longer to be the fastest in the
world because this fundamental dynamic
has changed
now that may seem like a very broad
point so i want to give you a more
concrete example
a real world example that you might see
and this is i think the only one example
that is uh participatory in this entire
talk slash workshop
which is the following let's say we have
some code and that code creates a data
set and we have some function that
operates on that data set
and we need to apply that function to
every element of this data set
now set aside that in practice you
probably would use numpy for something
like this
but let's say we do this in pure python
and we have a couple of options
in one option we might have a list
comprehension and another option we
might use
the map built in and we might pass it to
the list value constructor
and another option we might use that map
built in and we might use this
unpacking generalization in order to
pass it in order to construct a list to
build a list from this
and another option is we might just skip
the function entirely and just inline
this and just write a
standard list comprehension without any
function call which of these is the best
this is the only participatory part of
this this is the only question i'll ask
you but here i've given some
names for these and in the discord
channel if you'd like try to put in
order from fastest to least fast fc
the function in a comprehension lm list
with this map built in mu this map with
the unpacking syntax
and lc the straight up list
comprehension i'll give you about
15 seconds and the reason i'll only give
you 15 seconds is you don't need to
noodle on this for too long
and the reason i need new longest for
too long is the result may surprise you
you may be able to get the fastest but
you're not going to be able to go too
much further
let's take a look now it's actually
surprisingly easy for us to test this
and for some of you 15 seconds might
have been enough time to actually try
this
you know docker hub has versions of
python from 3.5 to
3.9 you can run a docker container you
can run this code using the time it
module in the standard library
you can give it some number of loops to
run and you could actually write some
code like this and this is what i
actually did in preparation for this
talk it took me about 10 minutes to do
and i want to give you a disclaimer
before i show you some of the results
the disclaimer is as follows
i didn't look that closely into the
docker files so maybe the different
versions of python
are being built with slightly different
options i
didn't really pay attention to all of
those we do know some details of what
happens when python runs in docker we
may have seen the news recently
that there are certain security modes
that are active inside the docker
container which cause our python
interpreter to be significantly slower
and when it's outside the doc container
setting all of that aside because it
doesn't really matter for the analysis
we're going to see
i also want to give you a couple other
important points just for your reference
i ran this on my surface pro
and i pinned my cpu frequency and i am
using an intel p
state governor and i'm running it on ac
power and there was nothing else running
at the same time and those are the
typical caveats we see about these kind
of benchmarks
and the most important caveat is i don't
care like seriously we're going to see
that this benchmark doesn't matter and
all those caveats and all that
qualification doesn't matter
but i'll tell you something important i
actually do care i very much care
because if i didn't care
i wouldn't be here i really do care and
i really hope that you're enjoying the
talk so far
let's take a look at those results
hopefully you had enough chance to try
and guess for yourself
let's take a look at what the actual
results are in python 3.5
the list comprehension is is the fastest
option the pure list comprehension
in fact in every single version of
python that we tested the list
comprehension is the fastest
when we get to the intuition section
we'll see why it should more or less
make sense but if we exclude the
comprehension from that and we look at
all of the other options
what we see is the function call in the
comprehension as fast as in python 3.5
and then in python 3.6 the list map is
fastest and you can see
it is significantly faster this is a
meaningful performance difference in
python 3.5 it's not that meaningful
performance difference
but in python 3.6 now it is a fairly
meaningful performance difference it's a
couple of percentage points
in python 3.7 it's the same but suddenly
in python 3.8
the unpacking in the map is the fastest
and in python 3.9 we see that same
behavior but there's not enough noise
there's not really enough
to enough signal there between python
between these two last two options of
python 3.8 and 3.9 but you can see
consistently for all the runs i did
this changed fundamentally if we made a
choice in python 3.5 that would not have
survived
until python 3.9 in other words a major
question would be
which of these do you choose well this
is actually very problematic
i need to figure out which of these do i
choose for the python version and i
certainly am not going to choose four of
them and seven
if sysdot version info equals 3.5 do
this one
if sysdot version equals 3.6 do that one
that modality
that checking is going to drown out the
speed of the underlying function itself
it'll add an enormous amount of noise
and mechanism to my code base
nobody ever does that in fact when
people actually do micro-optimizations
what do they do
they look at the current version of
python that they're using they see which
is the fastest and they delete all the
previous versions
and as a consequence if the version that
they thought was the fastest
is no longer the fastest over time and
you see from those
from those measurements just a very
simple very small structure
across four very very similar versions
of python we see a dramatic change of
which is the fastest and which is the
slowest and there is a dramatic
difference between the fastest and the
slopes
the choice that they would have made
would have been wrong and they would not
have ever been able to tell
because they would not have res they
would not have preserved the previous
pieces of code
that's somewhat surprising how would you
even track this over time i mean you
definitely even if you thought oh i want
to make sure this is always the fastest
let me keep all four versions
maybe new variants could come up well
that's not such a big deal but how would
you even track this over time that would
be very difficult
and you can think this question of which
version of python which version of
python might you have used to
to write this like maybe i should just
use the latest one i should write all my
code with the fastest
using whatever the head version of
python is 2.9 but then
that doesn't include the possibility
that my users might be using python 3.5
how do i even figure out from this
matrix of options which is the ideal
option
how would you even systematize this it's
unfortunate but there's no real way for
us to include any kind of structuring
information in our program
for us to have the program itself
dynamically choose which of the four is
the fastest
ideally if we had a very very smart
compiler a smart compiler
you could tell it declaratively this is
what i want to do and i could figure out
which of these are the fastest
but that level of structuring
information and that level of smartness
compiler is way beyond what we've seen
in python
and to a large degree it's even way
beyond what we've seen in most languages
other than languages that have
query optimizers like sql in fact
a more serious problem would be what if
we were using a tool like pandas
and pandas has a lot of fast paths so we
might have chosen the fastest
approach and then suddenly jeff freeback
adds another fast path to pandas
and the fastest approach that we chose
that was some contortion that was uglier
than the
stupid dumb approach that we that we
measured using scalene or pi spy is
being slow
is now faster because they added a fast
path for this dumb code
one surprising thing you'll find when
you actually try to optimize python code
is dumb python code ends up being fairly
fast
and one of the reasons for that is well
done python code probably pops up a lot
in performance benchmarks and because it
pops up a lot of performance benchmarks
it probably draws the attention of the
core developers because it draws the
attention of the core developers they
then go and optimize those paths
and so you have this kind of perverse
behavior where
your attempt to optimize may be
confounded
by the attempts of core developers to
optimize and you have this perverse
behavior where
somebody adds a fast path and your code
that you thought was fastest is no
longer fastest
now what you might have what you might
say is that's not a big deal i'll just
add regression tests
so i'll just add a little test to my to
my code base and i'll just test to see
if
it gets slower over time and that might
be a meaningful thing to do you might
actually have caught in the test results
that python 3.9 for whatever reason
is actually slower at some of those
benchmarks than python 3.8 maybe that's
because
you know as a rc build they haven't
added some optimizations in maybe docker
hub was building it slightly differently
i'm not sure but if you think about what
that regression test would tell you it
wouldn't tell you what the fastest it
would just tell you
did my code get slower so in practice
you weren't writing
the fastest possible code you were
writing the fastest enough possible code
the regression test implicitly tells me
that what you really cared about was was
my code fast enough
to meet some benchmark to meet some
baseline of performance
and as long as it stays at that baseline
i'm happy as long as it doesn't diverge
from that baseline you didn't really
care about what is the fastest code ever
you just cared was it the fast enough of
my use case well if that's the case
was it really that important for it to
be fast for your use case maybe you
should have gone back and really
understood you know is this the
important thing that i should be
spending my time on
now before we go before we go any deeper
in talking about this business side i
want to talk about intuition
because when you look at that example
you might say that's kind of a silly
example that list comprehension without
the function call
is always the fastest and it's always
the fastest buy a good margin
and i have some intuition and some my
intuition guides me to say
you know what between some of those
other options maybe it's not as
meaningful
but clearly i know the fastest option
i'm always going to pick the fastest
option and so this game that we play
here across different versions of python
doesn't really affect that one list pure
list comprehension without the function
call example
and my intuition would have guided me
correctly and i wouldn't have fallen
into this trap so let's talk a little
about intuition
we can see that is absolutely the case
in all of our versions of python
now if we compare python 3.5 we can
definitely see the
comprehension without the function call
is definitely is definitely
faster by significant margin than
anything else and so it was somewhat
artificial for us to exclude
that from our consideration now
let's let's try and figure out why that
might be and what we might do is we
might write a very simple piece of
python code
three functions one called fff one
called ggg and one called hhh
fff calls ggg ggg calls hhh hhh doesn't
do anything which is called fff
and what we might do is we might put we
might run our python interpreter under
gdb and we'll put a conditional
breakpoint
and we'll put a conditional breakpoint
on the actual function call
we'll look for a pi c function type
we'll actually see if it's that hhh
function and we'll try and put a break
point when that hhh function is
actually invoked by our python
interpreter and we'll see that at the c
level and so we'll put a breakpoint on
pi object vector call which is our part
of our python interpreter that handles
function calls so this is the c
function that handles the calling of
python functions and so
combined with this conditional
breakpoint and the breakpoint here
and the code as it's written here we
should have everything that we need to
kind of see what happens when a function
is called in python now bear in mind
this program does not do
anything interesting it defines three
functions and it calls them
and that you see you should see three
function calls that you know
serially performed and that's it nothing
else that's interesting
this is the stack trace that you get
this is the this is the stack trace that
you get from that
you can't even see what's on the screen
there are 31c
stack frames corresponding to a simple
dummy python program
that does three function calls 31c stack
frames
well if our intuition is that python
function calls are slow
this is pretty good evidence for that 30
31 stack frames and if we remove some of
the noise from that and we look at
a smaller subsection of this this is
approximately
a subsection of this that corresponds to
one function called so about one
function call in in python
corresponds to seven stack frames in c
to seven function calls in c you have to
call vector call
you call something else you call
something else you call something else
and that number one call function is you
can see the invocation of
this in this case would be the
invocation of uh hhh
from ggg so you can see there's quite a
lot of work there's quite a lot of splay
out
one line of python corresponds to many
lines of c code and you can think
well function calls really are expensive
and maybe the
maybe the speed of this function call is
what's dominating the overall speed of
this benchmark
and as a consequence if i eliminate that
entirely
then i'll see a significant speed up
which is why the pure comprehension
works
and the other examples are or where the
pure composition is the fastest in all
cases the other examples
have some other different behavior now
this might mislead you because that
might be the intuition that you get
oh if i want my python code to be fast
even if the execution environment around
me changes i should avoid things like
function calls i should build some
intuitions around what is fast what is
slow in python
things like function calls are slow and
i should just go ahead and
use that intuition to guide how i write
my code oh is there an extra function
call here
then i better not use it i'll try and
inline as many things as possible now
the reason this might
mislead you is that function calls
aren't necessarily slow now this is a
somewhat
weasely sentence because it could be the
case that further optimizations might
take those seven stack frames down to
fewer than seven stack frames
a lot of work has already been put into
optimizing what happens in a function
call in python
function calls are much faster in python
now than they were in
previous versions of python or in python
2. and so
that they're slow today doesn't
necessarily mean that somebody couldn't
go in and find some other fast pads to
make them fast tomorrow
and this is only talking about some
function calls this is function calls
where the
underlying function is user defined in
pure python and there may be fast paths
that you may have seen invoked already
for function calls where the function
itself is written in c or it's a
built-in function or something of that
nature
now even though this is kind of weasely
though because in practice in general
today yeah function calls are kind of
slow
but a and in practice when we actually
do benchmarks we see they they kind of
drown out
other other slowness
but something is kind of strange here
because in the python 3.7 example we
have two function calls
we call list this value constructor and
we call map this built-in function
and yet this is faster than calling one
function
map and then calling and then unpacking
this into a list
now obviously some of this is going to
be drowned out by
the numerous calls to this f function
but still
you would expect you wouldn't really
expect number two to be the fastest
of the two now there might be some
measurement error here i ran this over a
couple of samples
but something is kind of interesting
here one extra function call
seemed to not really make a difference
and if we take a look closely what the
byte code is you know and in twice 3.7
this line is a call function and it does
invoke many many lines of c
you know seven stack frames of c and the
other line is a build list
unpack in python 3.9 it changes slightly
to a list extend
byte code and in python 3.9 this latter
version
is now slightly barely measurably faster
but you can see you know this guidance
of oh just avoid function calls would
have failed this in this example because
it doesn't really give us
a clear indication of which one of these
would be faster now you could say well
they didn't take into account the number
of times
this behavior was invoked but still
there's something somewhat missing here
fundamentally i think a better guidance
from this is the intuition that python
itself is slow
or maybe that invoking byte code is slow
or maybe that doing
work at all is slow if you need to do
some work it's going to be slow
and an intuition you might have that's
related to this is that dynamic dispatch
is slow
you know every time we have to call
perform some operation in python we do
dynamic dispatch
and there's many many lines of c
corresponding to one line of python
and this is where the slowness of python
comes and we may have seen this before
when we multiply
x and y this gives you a binary multiply
byte code which calls pi number
multiplied to c level
which steps later calls long multiply to
actually perform the multiplication if
this thing happens to be
two integer numbers and if we have a
if we have an addition this calls not
binary multiply but in this case binary
binary add which calls pi number add
which eventually calls long ad
and if these happen to be something like
strings instead of it'll still go binary
add then pi number add
and then eventually some kind of string
concatenate or list concatenate or tuple
concatenate based off what it is
and you might say well this dynamic
dispatch is adding many many lines of c
for one line of python and so one way
that i could make my python interpreter
fundamentally faster
is to eliminate this dynamic dispatch
this is the source of all of my worries
and that's my intuition but in fact if
you take a look at the binary add code
you'll see that somebody has already
gone in and added in this specialization
when you do binary add on two python
objects
if they both happen to be exact unicode
objects you do a unicode concatenate and
you do not do this dynamic dispatch
and so you might say um that intuition
was actually pretty good
because that intuition is exactly why
somebody added this line of code
but if you scroll up just a little bit
above those lines of code you'll see
this comment
please do not try to micro optimize in
plus int
using bytecode it doesn't work it's
worthless it doesn't do anything
in practice if you have ever thought
dynamic dispatch is the reason why
python is slow
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to try to remove dynamic dispatch by
adding specialization operations at my
ce val loop level
go ahead and try it you won't actually
get any measurable performance outside
of
synthetic micro benchmarks and so it's
not dynamic dispatch this
this intuition that we have about
dynamic dispatch being slow
is again misleading us now what we might
think is
you know wouldn't it be nice if python
could do some kind of optimization so if
we have a function
of f and it returns x and i guess this
function should have taken x as an
argument but
you'll you'll you'll accept my apologies
for the typo
python can perform some optimization
notes you can do constant folding and
you'll see that
in practice what python will do is it'll
fold that one plus one into two
and so it'll perform this very simple
optimization to eliminate
one unnecessary binary add if there were
another function g
and it called f and it added one to f
unfortunately what we might like python
to be able to do is to perform
optimizations between the two of these
to fuse them together but
unfortunately python functions are very
opaque and so there is not the
possibility for the python
interpreter to perform this kind of
inlining and so we might say
um this is another intuition you know
the reason why python is slow is because
we don't have the ability to perform
cross-function in lining type
optimizations we can't have one function
c into another function and see into
that other function and then use some
information
that's available in that other function
in order to perform optimizations and
that might be our guidance
and we might use that guidance to draw
ourselves to tools like number but for
those of you who actually use number you
can see number is kind of hit or miss
it is a great tool to use because you
just add a decorator number.jit to the
top of your code if it's faster
move on with your life if it's not
faster figure out something else
but there's still something missing here
because
in practice when we use number. i'm sure
some of you have tried using number.jet
and you've
seen no actual speedup on the underlying
code so just being able
to add enough little structuring in so
you can perform
so you can make these functions no
longer opaque but perform
optimizations between them doesn't seem
to be enough now another thing you might
say is my intuition is that loading
variables in python is slow low global
is slow
and so if i have to optimize my python
code what i'll do is i'll take load
globals and i'll turn them into load
local so i'll do these little tricks
like hiding variables in keyword
arguments and you'll see this in the
python standard library uh the inspect
module
which the json module does in a couple
places and this was very much the case
it used to be the case that when you
load a global variable it was a
dictionary lookup and that was slow
and some optimizations have been added
to speed up looking up global variables
if you ever look at the byte code and
you wonder why
load local or why loading a local
variable is actually called load fast
is because there an optimization was
added there where loading a local
variable
in the python byte code is not a
dictionary lookup it's just a cra lookup
and so there was definitely a case where
somebody looked at that and said oh this
is actually kind of slow
similarly you might have some intuition
about method lookups and you might say
oh method lookups are slow every time i
do an a dot x
that's slow so if i do that in a tight
loop it's probably a bad idea so i
should move that out of a loop
but method lookup was itself optimized
in fairly recent versions of python as
well
and so some of these intuitions may only
be timely around a particular view of
how python works
as of when you learned that intuition in
the case of something like load global
you might say well the reason why this
python code is slow even though
it just calls len in a loop is that
every single time that loop goes
it has to look up that lend variable in
the global scope and python is so
dynamic and somebody could have swapped
out that lend variable so it has to
perform this lookup every single time
and that's a lot of redundant work
that's being done
and you might say wouldn't it be nice if
python had some kind of constantness
like javascript has and maybe if it had
this kind of const-ness
we could start to edge away we could
start to hedge
ourselves against some of the dynamic
nature of python perform these
optimizations
this is something that i haven't seen a
lot of people try in trying to improve
the python interpreter itself
it is something that i would be very
curious to see how it works but i would
be somewhat surprised if you saw
significant speed ups because
areas of python that people have seen
that are slow like low global have
already had some work put into them
you might say that this is actually a
very similar optimization approach to
something you've used in practice pi pi
you can think a tool like pi pi figures
out oh there's fast paths and slow pads
and so if len doesn't really change
the fast path will assume that it
doesn't change it'll perform some kind
of jitting
and based off that jitting we'll be able
to eliminate redundant operations
but if we're wrong about that jitting
we'll go down a slow path and look it up
and so we get
the same behavior with faster
performance in practice i don't know
that i've actually seen pi pi in a very
similar way to number
guaranteed provide performance to code
and unfortunately one thing that we see
about pi pi is
the support for tools like numpy and
pandas
you know without that it's really not a
non-starter
what i would say fundamentally here our
intuition is not really that
it's not should not really be built
around oh this particular structure is
slow
method lookup is slow load global is
slow python function calls are slow
so much as each one of these are missing
some kind of structuring
and in the absence of this kind of
structuring we have no choice but for
this code to be slow
this brings us to the next to the next
letter the s the s for structure and
this is where we want to spend the most
of our attention
most of our time when we talk about
python and making python code fast one
of the topics that some
sometimes comes up is generators and for
those of you who are data scientists and
not data engineers
you might have seen some examples of
generators where they're doing some kind
of data processing
and you were very unimpressed you saw
somebody write some code where they had
a generator that squared a bunch of
numbers
they applied it to a range of a bunch of
numbers to build a list
and when you actually looked at you said
you know what that is kind of cool the
generator is kind of a cool structure
but you know what i just use numpy and
the code is shorter and it's a lot
easier to read
and if i actually measure this the numpy
code is way faster
and you know what i didn't even measure
this fairly i just measured the whole
block not including the setup so the
numpy code is way faster
including the construction of this one
million element numpy array
in the case of the comprehension syntax
with a generator that range object is
not a concrete collection and so this is
a very unfair comparison and even in the
unfair comparison the numpy code is 200
times faster
and so when you look at that you might
say come on like
don't don't start telling me about
generators in terms of optimization this
is clearly adding nothing to my python
code
numpy is how i do fast computational
code in python generators are just a
non-starter
they're cool they're not they're fun to
read about but they don't actually do
anything to make my code faster
but i would argue that you are very very
wrong
and the reason i would argue that you're
very wrong is what if your code looked
like this you have a generator
you perform one square and then you
break and stop performing the operation
fundamentally what's making your code
slow is that it has to do some work
if you didn't do any work then the code
wasn't slow fundamentally those
those numpy operations are are eager and
so
even if you didn't look at all the
values that were being performed it's
fairly difficult for you to say oh
only perform the values as i as i ask
for them and in this particular
case this generator code is actually
significantly faster because it doesn't
do anything
and if you think about that you might
say that's very synthetic like okay
what's the point but when you start to
think about this a little bit deeper
what you can think is
the generator structuring actually
allows you to control how much work is
being done
and if you can more precisely control
the amount of work is being done
to match the work that needs to be done
you can sometimes find optimization
because it is fundamentally the case
that
for the most part doing less work is
going to be faster
now that's not always correct so don't
be too misled by that because we have
seen cases where
as a consequence of cpu speculate
speculation mechanisms
or confounding factors like branch
misprediction it is sometimes the case
that doing extra work is faster
than having to encode a modality in
other words you have almost certainly
seen a case with a numpy and d array
where you performed two operations and a
conditional and
instead of choosing which of the two
operations you wanted to perform with
some kind of modality some
if else you found that it was faster to
perform both of them simultaneously and
then just multiply one by zero and
multiply one by
one and then add them together because
what you can think is the speculative
units
of execution inside your processor can
perform both of these in parallel and
just throw away the work and if you
think about
cpu speculation you can think oh in many
cases that's exactly what happens
it's often times faster to go ahead and
do work and throw it away
than to try to wait to figure out if you
need to do that work or not and so this
idea of doing less work is necessarily
faster or better than doing more work
is not quite correct it needs a couple
more qualifications
than simply that but for the most part
if you can control the amount of work
that's done
for the most part at the macro scale
you'll probably see
some kind of optimization and this is
what generators give you and this is why
generators are such a powerful mechanism
for for optimization even though you
almost certainly have
never used them as a computational
entity in any of your numpy or pandas
code and you will never use them as a
computational
numpy pattern as code what you will use
them for is program structuring
and this is the most critical part let's
say you have
a a piece of code and it has three
functions in it f g and h and your
program is the composition of these
three functions f or you call h on your
data set which and you call g
on the result of that and you call f on
the result of that and if you think
about that what is fc well f sees
some concrete result what is gc some
concrete results
and only hc is the initial data set
because functions as a unit of
computation
are fundamentally eager composition of
functions can't
see that that composition of functions
exist there's not sufficient program
structuring
if you were to instead think of these as
two functions like select and process
and you were to say okay
here i do some processing of some data
set i do some selecting of those data
sets
you can see there's probably a problem
in this code you do the processing and
then you select the items from that
processing that you want
if that selecting operation was not was
not or did not require
something that was computed by that
processing you might find
that that selecting might actually
eliminate items that you
spent time processing this is a very
common problem if you've used hadoop
you've seen this problem before and you
may
have seen it called predica push down it
is very much the case in query
optimization tools that often times when
we have
a a select and a process we want to take
that select and push it down as far as
possible
to eliminate items for processing as
early as we can
to reduce the total amount of work that
we need to do and in the case of these
two being written as functions
unfortunately we can't do that the
select function sees
the result of that process function and
it can't perform predicate push down
this is impossible
but this is where generators are such a
powerful technique
what you could do is you could say oh my
process is a is a generator
and my select is a generator now by
themselves this doesn't do anything
but you could say my process is a
generator for each element of the data
set we perform some function on that
and i'll just add a little decorator
called tagged to it and i'll call this a
map operation
and i'll say my select as a generator
for each element of my data set i'll
perform some condition on it and if i
meet that condition i'll yield that
element and i'll also tag this i'll call
this a filter
and this might not seem very interesting
like what is this decorator we have to
probably write it ourselves what is map
what does filter mean
well if you think about it we could
write this decorator like this what it
does is it creates a class called gen
and it wraps the generator just stores
those tags somewhere
just stores that information that you
that you had there somewhere
and when you call this class that you
defined here
all it does is it
invokes the generator to give you the
generator instance with the arguments so
this didn't really do anything it stored
that information didn't use it for
anything
didn't didn't go anywhere but then you
might say you know what instead of
returning that
raw generator instance what if i mock
out that generator instance
what if i create my own instance type
and what i'll do is i'll have its next
just call the next on
the generator instance and in the iter
i'll just create the generator instance
but in the iter which gives me that
general instance what i'll do
is i'll look at the tags and i'll do
something with the text
i'll see if i have a filter on a map and
if i have a filter on a map in that
particular order i'll perform predicate
push down by swapping them
the generator here is giving you some
kind of program structuring because
those two generators
exist at runtime and because they are
lazy computational units because they're
computational thunks they can see each
other
because they can see each other they can
operate on each other because they can
operate in each other
that gen that program structuring that
is now created
by that generator structuring that you
have can be used to
do things like predicate push down which
can then lead to optimizations later
in other words your first optimization
might look like this if you have a
filter and a map and it's a filter
being composed with the map in that
particular order swap the order so you
do the map
you do the filter first in the map
second and obviously in this particular
case we don't have enough structured
information here to know if this is safe
or not
maybe the filter requires information
that was created by the map but
obviously you can think if you wanted to
extend this example very slightly
you can encode a little bit more
information in this in order to be able
to determine
whether this predicate push down could
be done or not now what's very
interesting here is
i have shown you how you can do
predicate push down in python using
generators
in about two lines of actual core
computational code and maybe
15 lines of structuring code it's a very
very simple framework and it probably
won't work for many problems but you can
think
even this simple framework shows you the
possibility of generators as a
structuring tool
leading to optimization and the
underlying computational elements that
you work on
can still be your numpy and d array but
the program structuring element then
structures that program
to eliminate redundant computations that
are then performed within that
computational domain
might make use of this generator
structure now you can think you could do
some very interesting things here you
could say if
this g if the generator itself is is the
process generator and the argument to it
is the select generator
swap them out fuse them so perform some
kind of generator diffusion
you can't do that on functions they they
compute eagerly but i'm generators
because they compute
lazily and because they give you the
actual structure they give you that
information that's retained you can do
some very fancy things you can swap out
f of g for some fused version that's
written in c that's highly optimized for
the particular problem that you're
solving
and so even if f and g happen to be
elements that themselves
use pandas or numpy for their actual
computation
because you've built the structure of
your program in this way you can perform
optimizations that then
take combinations of numpy operations or
penis operations
and elide operations that are
unnecessary or swap out
specific operations for operations that
might fuse things together
now this kind of program structure you
may have seen before and you may have
and when you think about it you may have
seen this kind of program structuring
before and before we get to that i want
to talk a little bit about
what i mean by the overall program
structuring so when you think about the
code that you write you might think
about the code as having some core to it
you might call that core some root and
there's some portions that extend from
that root and there are some leaves
when you think about your code in this
way you might say well oftentimes i have
areas of high churn and areas of low
turn at the root i have low turn
ideally for a well for a well produced
piece of software
i have low turn at the root but i may
have high turn at the leaf and in fact i
may even design my program so that
there's
very high turn at the leaf to limit the
amount of churn that i have at the root
in other words what you might think is
that at the root level you have some
kind of program structure you've decided
i need to encode certain guarantees
about the way that my program works or
certain information
that can then be used at the leaves in
order to perform micro optimizations
in our first view of the micro
optimization we were guiding this with
just measurements and we didn't really
think about it in terms of the structure
of our code base
one of the problems that we saw with
those micro optimizations are no longer
valid
if the execution environment around you
changes but if we think about
software programming as a dynamic
process it is always the case that our
code base will change there's always
going to be some churn
if we isolate our turn to the leaf level
because that leaf level has no further
dependencies
it's a very safe type of turn to have
and it's a very common type of turn and
so if we limit our micro optimizations
to that leaf level
even if it's the case those micro
optimizations change over time we might
just have to revisit them every
so often and then see if which ones work
if those micro optimizations occur at
the root level we could lead to some
problem because we might end up
rewriting code fundamentally at the root
level
that causes downstream problems that
causes a lot of churn
in the pieces that depend on that and so
what we generally want to have the case
to be
when we design our program is that we
have some fundamental program optim
program structure that exists at the
root of our program that makes it
possible
to do micro optimization of the leaf if
you think about that predicate push down
formulation
that was program structuring at the root
we structured these computational
entities as generators
and then at the leaves we perform some
kind of fusing or some kind of predicate
push-down or some other kind of
optimization
and this in practice tends to work well
if you think about this kind of
generated structure you may have seen it
before
if fundamentally in this generator
structuring what we're doing is we're
making these computational entities
first class then we can manipulate them
later
you might have seen this in the form of
a computational dag instead of
executing some computation you construct
a dag and then you selectively
re-execute portions of that graph
as those portions get dirty in fact you
may even see a framework like desk that
gives you the ability to
exploit this kind of structuring
information to pick the most efficient
execution back in
and so this is actually a fairly
effective way to write python code
in a structured fashion that will lead
to optimizations at that leaf level
and it's a much more effective way to
think about this than thinking about it
in terms of these
very simplistic intuitions and then
trying to aim
try to just put number.jet all over the
place but this program structure goes a
little bit deeper than just that
it is a very successful approach for
high performance but there's another
type of program structuring that you
might see
now before we get into that other type i
want to just kind of recap for you
the general approach that i'm suggesting
use program structuring at the root of
your program
this encodes important structural
information like i have some composition
of functions
because you've encoded that information
you are then allowed to exploit that
information to eliminate redundant work
or to perform some kind of
specialization on that work
like fusing two function calls or two
generators into a fused
hyper-optimized c version and this is
how you exploit the structuring
to gain performance at that leaf level
over the long term of your project
itself
there are other program structurings
that you may have seen before that are
similarly effective
let's say that you have some program and
in that program you have individual data
items and they're represented as python
objects a single python object your data
set is just a python list of these
python
objects it's a very simple modeling of a
problem now obviously if you're a pandas
user you might skip this step entirely
and go straight to pandas but let's
pretend that you're starting with the
very basics
and you're trying to reach for as little
as as little as possible in your python
interpreter as little as possible even
from your standard library so you might
start with something like this
and the moment that you need to scale
this up to 10 million items you might
see the memory use is very high the
reason the memory used to be very high
is that this individual class object has
a dict object associated with it if you
look at the size of this thing
this thing has 64 bytes in size python
dictionaries are very large and so
python classes
instances of python classes are very
large so they carry this information
around but that datum doesn't really
have that much information
in fact there's no information in it and
so you can see paying 64 bytes
for each individual data it's going to
blow up your memory and you're not going
to be able to scale this
now you might say well an easy way to do
this is i could use like a name tuple
and so the name tuple's a little bit
smaller than a custom python class
it doesn't have it doesn't have that
dick on it and so i will see a
performance benefit or you might say
let me use slots the moment you say
let me use slots you're going down
exactly the wrong path
i would argue that the reason i put this
talk together is
basically for the purposes of just this
one slide i
hate talks about slots slots is not
a useless tool it is useful in a
particular niche to accomplish a
particular goal
but it is way over hyped and it is an
incredibly
misleading approach to optimization in
python if you have a system in python
and you're seeing
it's slow uh my memory use is out of
control
and maybe it's slow because the data
items in python are allocated on the
heap and so they're not contiguous so if
you're doing some kind of
aggregate operation some kind of
broadcasted operation
or vectorized operation you can't prefer
you know you're doing multiple memory
lookups that aren't cache coherent
so you know you're making no use of your
l1 cache because you're jumping all
throughout memory
to load this up so you may have seen
that problem before slots doesn't affect
that at all but at least it'll affect
the size
of this thing and so maybe if you're
lucky and these things get allocated
next to each other they'll at least be
packed close enough to fit into a cache
line
maybe fundamentally when you when you
think about slots for optimization
you're going down the absolute wrong
path because slots has
never ever made somebody's python
program meaningfully
less intensive in terms of memory there
is another approach
that is much more successful for this
and the approach looks like this
instead of looking at slots oops instead
of looking at slots which won't help you
because even if you use slots you still
have a python object and if you have a
python object you still have to store
a lot of additional information even
though this is just a very small data
item you have to store a pointer to its
op type you have to store its ref count
if you have this pi head extra you may
have to store the link list as well
it's quite a lot of information you have
to store you end up being boxed in
and this is something of a pun because
fundamentally what you're dealing with
are box types
and when you think about that you might
say well hold on a second this is why
languages like java have boxed versus
unbox types because the box types are
fairly intensive in terms of the amount
of memory they use and this has some
other consequences
in terms of you know things don't fit
into cache lines anymore
now if i showed you some code that
looked like this you know multiply these
entities
and we park this question of the size of
these objects for a moment
we might say it would be very nice if
this kind of multiplication could be
automatically parallelized
that could lead to some kind of
performance you know we have multiple
cores we have multiple alus and if we
could parallelize this
we could do more work in the same unit
of time but the problem is and you may
not be able to see this code too clearly
but the problem is
that if these if this code is written in
python and these are python objects
these python objects could have any
arbitrary behavior in this particular
case here i have an object
and this object has the ability to
mutate objects that it's referring to
while it itself is being added so you
add one to some object and because it
has a reference to some other object it
goes and mutates this other object
because that is not visible to the
python interpreter and the python
interpreter cannot see that
python interpreter can't say i'm
performing the summation
if i change this object it has no
effects outside of this object by the
interpreter does not have enough
structural information in order to
determine that as a consequence the
python interpreter cannot
naively auto-parallelize any sort of
aggregate operation
because it necessarily has to do them in
the order that is specified lexically in
the order that you might specify it with
a naive execution model
because you could have these weird
behaviors that somebody has added to
their classes
and so what you might instead do is you
might say you know what
instead of having these in a list i'll
put these into a custom class called a
data set
and in my data set i'll just store the
data items and then you know what i
won't
i won't drop into pure python code i'll
have these operations on the outside of
my data set like ink
to go through the data set and increment
everything and when you do that you'll
see
well nothing's really changed i'm still
using the same amount of memory it's
still as slow as ever
but then you might say you know what why
don't i just use psython and i'll swap
out this class with the version in
cyclone and the moment i do that i say
you know what
why am i doing self.data equals data in
psython why don't i just extract when i
unbox these python objects and store
them contiguously
in a c array and when i do that i end up
getting some very interesting
some benefits from this the store
continues in a cra so when you're
performing aggregate operations later on
in your sythenized code you can now make
use of things like cache coherence
they're much smaller in terms of their
use because they're now packed to
whatever the smallest amount of space
that's needed in order to store that
data
and because they're cache coherent when
you're performing operations on these
you're not seeing a lot of cache misses
that are leading to very poor
performance
you might you might also be doing so you
might be adding restrictions because
you're saying
oh my little data set class here is
taking these objects and unboxing them
and because it's unboxing them some of
these custom behaviors can't be
preserved
and so what i'm doing is i'm adding a
restriction that these custom behaviors
can't exist
and if you think about this a little bit
you might think haven't i
seen something that looks like this like
a dataset class where the contents are
required to be machine typed
they're required to be contiguous in
memory because they're machine typed
there's no dynamic dispatch on these and
there's no interdependencies hold on a
second that's a numpy and d array
this is what a numpy and d array is the
numpy and dra is the idea that you can
create a restricted computation domain
that restricted computation domain
gives you the ability to store items in
an
unboxed fashion so that they are
optimized for the op
for the operations you want to perform
boxing and unboxing happens at the
at the edges of this so whenever you
actually do an indexing operation on the
ndra it'll take the c int and give you a
python int and remember the nd arrays
integers are not python integers they're
in 8s in 16s in 32s or in 64s
they are machine typed ins when you
perform an operation in indira you don't
say four x and nd array
perform something what you do is you say
nd array do a dot sum
and it figures out how it wants to do
that sum and because it has drawn a line
around this data set and
inside inside of its own controlled
access to
its own contents it is able to then
perform optimizations
subject to whatever execution
environment that it finds itself in
optimization such as instead of doing
dynamic dispatch and every binary
multiplier or binary add
i'll just use an i ad or a or a f ad
i'll just use the exact assembly
language structure i'll use some avx
instruction instead
in fact this is a pattern that you may
have seen many times in many places
this is the general idea of a restricted
computation domain this is
probably one of the more common and most
successful approaches for optimization
in python
what you see is if you have a program
and that program interacts with many
data items and those data items are
starting to blow you up in memory and
they're not
coherent so computations on them are
slow what you do is you draw a line
around those data items you call it a
manager class or a data set class or a
numpy ndra or a pandas data frame
you call this a restricted computation
domain it's a restricted computation
domain because little domain in which
the computations are performed
you no longer extract those objects back
into box python objects you perform all
the computations inside that domain
you always do numpy ndra dot sum or
pandas
column. whatever and you know from when
you're dealing with pandas anytime
somebody does something pandas inner
rows or they do a dot apply or any
operation that pulls the data out of
pandas it's always slow
well this is the reason why as long as
you're inside the pandas computation
domain
pandas is able to exploit whatever
tricks it can figure out to make the
code inside of it fast
the moment you pull this out into
generalized python you no longer have
that ability to exploit that information
in the generalized domain of python
there's too much dynamicness and too
much freedom with what you're able to do
within the numpy and dra these are
machine typed floats there's no
interdependencies between them
they're you know adding two of these has
a very well-defined behavior that can be
implemented
in a single assembly language
instruction i can make full use of my
multiple cores my multiple alus
i can make full use of my vectorized
instructions and everything is very
compact because i store just enough
information that i need
if you think about some tools in python
that are that are very common but very
slow think about something like
network x network x gives you the
ability to represent a graph and if you
ever use network x one of the problems
you've seen with network x is once you
get to a graph of a particular size
you start running out of memory and
everything you know path finding other
operations become very slow
why is that well network x's modeling of
the underlying graph is of a dictionary
dictionary dictionaries
network x does represent a registered
computation domain they just haven't
gone the whole way
one of the things that they want to do
with network x is make sure that you
could always import it into
a python project you can always you
didn't have to have any c dependencies
to build it so it's pure python
and as a consequence they weren't able
to take this all the way but if you
think about it the network x digraph or
graph object
give you the ability to draw a little
line around the underlying objects that
are contained the edges and the nodes
inside that network x if somebody wanted
to perform some optimizations what they
could do
is they could eliminate the ability to
pierce that veil they could swap out
this dict addictive dick's
representation and they could start
storing things that are more compact
more optimized fashion
more specialized the actual problems
they're solving now unfortunately in the
case of network text this wouldn't be as
easy as i'm saying that it would be
because people still have certain
assumptions around the way that network
x digraph or the network fix graph is
used
certain assumptions like the nodes can
be any arbitrary python object
and what what you've almost certainly
seen is if you try to create a numpy nd
array that contains pi objects or a
pandas data frame that contains pi
objects
you see that the performance there is
not meaningfully better than just
putting it into a python list
this only really works if you're able to
put sufficient restrictions around the
domain and so in the case of network x
the idea wasn't taken all the way
because maybe there weren't enough
restrictions that could be added
without significantly degrading the
general the generality of the tool
itself
now if you think about this what you can
think is that
generally the process is you have a
bunch of data items that are inside
individually boxed and then you just
kind of box them up with some domain
you put restrictions around them you
exploit those restrictions and so this
gives you
something like the numpy and array or
the pandas array series and data frame
now if you have
some code that looks like this you have
some data set you process this data set
and you process this data set again so
you do two two operations here
even if you were to create a restricted
computation domain
like you were and you were to switch
this code here into code like this so
instead of
performing these operations in the
python byte code with this list
comprehension syntax and a function call
you're performing them inside the domain
you're still going to run into trouble
because in between the
creation of ys and zs there's a
temporary and you've seen this in numpy
and you've seen this
before in larger computations there's
temporaries that are created and they
use a lot of memory but you never really
do anything with them
unfortunately there's not enough program
structure information here in python for
python to know a ys is only really used
in this program
in order to create zs and even if we
chain these together
still we create this the result of this
first operation and then the result of
the second operation
and so even if we chain these we don't
really get anything because one
temporary is created that temporary is
used and unfortunately there's not
enough information here because these
are functions not generators to let us
know oh
let's stack these operations or a few of
these operations and so there's still
some issues with this computation domain
well one of the things you might try and
do is you might try to find a way to
fuse them so you might try to add that
program information and so one thing you
might do is you might say instead of
having
two individual python functions that i
call it some chain fashion i have one
function that i encode the chaining of
these operations
as a string this is basically numpy ein
sum
or num expert all it is is the idea that
you don't have sufficient structural
information in your code in order to see
how these two operations are being
performed in order to remove or elide
temporaries in order to do less work
and so numpy einsam is a very popular
tool because it gives you a string based
language
for defining transformations on a numpy
and d array num expert is the very same
thing
string based language for defining
operations on a numpy and d array
and because it can see the entire
operation as a single entity and it can
do can build an ast from it itself and
it has that program structuring
information
albeit provided in a fairly clumsy api
it's able to then perform those
optimizations later and this you can see
is a
root level choice that then leads to
leaf level optimizations
this leads us to our second s
specialization and i don't want to talk
about this too much but i do want to
just draw your attention to the idea
that optimization fundamentally
is specialization in other words let's
say we have a numpy program and it takes
the numbers from 0 up to but not
including 10 and it sums them together
we can perform some optimizations on
this in order to make this faster
like numpy a range is never going to
change the sum of the values from 0 to 9
is never going to change
we could perform an optimization like or
we could perform some kind of
specialization like say
oh these are specifically in aids now in
the case of numpy that's not a really
big deal but if you compare this like
the python program where they're
ins with automatic promotion yeah from
insult automatic promotion the innate
reduces a lot of extra work that you
have to do
but an even better specialization would
just be to reduce this program to the
number 45.
very very smart compilers like the
haskell compiler can do this they can
see oh these are constant expressions
and i'll just reduce the entire program
into a single constant expression
python is not able to see it because it
does not have sufficient structuring
information
it can do constant folding in some very
very limited cases but even constant
folding like string operations
are just too opaque for python to be
able to see what you can think is
specialization fundamentally requires
program information
and python by virtue its dynamic nature
has very
limited ability to provide that program
information but
if you think about this what you really
want is not just program information but
program
structuring when you think about python
you can think well this is why python is
slow because it doesn't really provide
us it's too dynamic and it doesn't
provide this as program structure this
program information
it's too dynamic maybe it provides us
some kind of structure or some kind of
information but things are changing all
the time so we have to repeatedly check
things we have to repeatedly dynamic
dispatch
we have to repeatedly look things up to
see if somebody swapped out our len
function for us
but another interesting thing about
python is python is very humane
and so what we can see is that python is
actually a very rich language a lot of
rich metaphors are provided to us
these rich metaphors are things like
generators you know the object model
or context managers these rich metaphors
are very easy to use
in 15 lines of code i can build a
framework for you that uses generators
that gives you just enough information
to do some very very sophisticated
things
like fusing of computational units that
can build things like
you know a graph framework in a previous
talk called more about generators at pi
data london 2017 or 2018
i built a dag framework in about 45
lines of code
using generators obviously it was a toy
framework here in this case
about 15 lines of code i built a
predicate push down framework for you in
python
obviously again it was a toy problem but
you can see these metaphors are very
easy to use
very little code you can expose enough
human level information structural level
information to then
employ to get ad hoc structuring that
leads to optimizations and so what you
can think is at the root level what you
want to do
is you want to use the fundamental
humaneness and the fundamental program
structuring mechanisms provided to you
by python to encode structured
information
at the leaf level you want to exploit
the structure information and then
even if things change around you you
will have built into this process the
idea that at the leaf level as long as
certain assumptions that are still met
and these may be more fundamental
assumptions assumptions like
the less work that i do the less time
that it takes
those are assumptions that are less
likely to change over time obviously
we don't know what computers will look
like in 30 or 40 or 50 years
and so over the very long scale some of
those assumptions at that root level may
be wrong
but we can generally make educated
guesses about what they might be
and those educated guesses may survive
much better
than the kind of guesses we saw when
we're trying to micro-optimize single
lines of python code
at the root level we encode structure
information at the leaf level we exploit
the structure information
we structure that information based on
some intuition but not
really because the problem here is our
intuitions are not always right
maybe we make use of broad intuitions
like doing less work is better or
being able to see what you're doing is
better and so it's not really
structuring based on the intuition so
much of structuring it based on the
problem
we say this is the these are the aspects
of my problem the facets of my problem
these are the aspects of my problem like
we're doing some kind of composition and
we want to
and some node and some graph becomes
dirty so we want to do the minimum
amount of computation so we need to be
able to track
when something is dirty when something's
clean we will track and build that
dag for us something like what das does
or other frameworks do
and instead of basing that structuring
on intuition we create structurings that
lead to better intuitions
when you use numpy and pandas and you'll
see a talk later today about optimizing
pandas one of the things that you might
see is
well-designed libraries in python that
provide the structural information
lead to clear intuitions about how to
use them and so if you
know a couple of rules about pandas like
stay inside the pandas data frame as
much as possible
avoid dot apply because that pulls you
out of the data frame avoid dot group
buy because that group by
has parts that are written in pure
python in fact just kind of avoid
dumping into python try and keep
everything inside the
the pandas array or nd array back end as
possible
just just that gets you about 90 of the
way to faster pandas code
and you can see you know i i wrote some
panda's code in order to do the
performance analysis for this
and the pandas code had some areas where
i said can i do this inside pandas or i
have to drop out to like a python loop
and in some cases i said you know what
it doesn't matter if i drop out to a
python loop because i'm only iterating
it three times
but in other cases i said i should stay
inside pandas because i'm iterating for
this the entire data set
and so if i think about this in terms of
my asymptotic complexity i might say
asymptotically i want to always try and
stay what's inside the research
computation domain the structuring that
was provided to me by that tool led to
that intuition
which led to a very good guide in
general
for these optimizations to work and so
what i want to leave you with
at the end of this talk is that when we
look at successful optimization
techniques like das
or numpy or pandas or numba or anything
that you write yourself
it's not about slots it's not about
jitting
it's about a particular conceptual
framework and that framework is
you want to separate your code at the
root level of the leaf level at the root
level you want to encode
structural information that leads to
optimizations at the leaf level and i've
shown you two of those kind of
structures
one of them is making visible in your
program
the computational units using a
mechanism like generators
and because you make them visible then
you can perform optimization the leaf
level to fuse them to a light them
to swap them out or making use of this
restricted computer
computational domain pattern and so you
know you
draw a red line around your data items
and inside that dot items you add some
restrictions and you say within that
restricted computation domain
we do whatever we want to make this as
fast as possible we might swap out
our internal code so the numpy and
dra.sum might swap out over time
but for the most part from the high
level view of this program we just call
it that sum the code is readable and
inside the computation domain we figure
out how to perform those micro
optimizations
and so given this framework of missi i
hope that you've gotten a better sense
for how to conceptualize what
optimization is all about in python what
makes python code fast or slow
i hope this has managed to dismantle
some some
or disabused you of some
misapprehensions around or some
mistaken views around what optimization
means or what you can do to lead to
python code
yes it is the case calling python
functions is slow today will that be the
case
in two years three years four years five
years i don't know probably
but i couldn't say definitively and i
wouldn't necessarily want to use that in
order to guide myself to better code
what i want to use to guide myself to
better faster code would be exploiting
underlying structuring information
making use of the features that python
has to offer and so
when you think about optimization python
always come back to this m-i-s-s-i
framework where m-i-s-s-i stands for my
isn't structuring surprisingly important
i'm james powell thank you very much
thank you so much that was uh that was
really inspiring
um so i i think i saw some questions
already pop up in the
in the discord maybe there's also some
questions here and soon
um i also have some questions myself
because
you do you know whether there's any of
these
um restricted computation domain
initiatives
for graph libraries so
i i have a study group
that has been researching better graph
implementations
we're on sabbatical right now given the
current circumstances but we're trying
to look into whether it's possible to
write
a better tool than network x for higher
performance graph computing
the limitation is one of the great
things about network x is it's pure
python
and so you don't need to use conda you
don't need to build anything
if we're willing to release ourselves
from that restriction
it should be very fairly easy to write
something that gives us
better behavior making use of this now
there's some other issues with network x
that are separate from the performance
aspect like that it doesn't have copy on
write
that it doesn't give the ability to
create immutable graphs that doesn't
have um
that the the algorithms that are
implemented are too opaque
and that the api is kind of kind of
matte plot libby it's kind of
kind of uh old uh but those are those
are something separate from the idea of
like network x having a serious
computation i mean there are tools like
if you look at graph tool which is
written in c plus plus with python
bindings
it gives you you know some high
performance c plus plus back end
the thing is it's just impossible to
build i tried to build it once and i ran
out of
on a machine that had eight gigs of ram
and i ran out of ram
right now memory just building things so
i think i think you can find something
that's
got the same uh ease of use of network x
but you swap out the back end a little
bit better
i also see in the chutney graph tool is
unbuildable
is it really unbuildable yes i i think
someone else tried it as well yeah
okay interesting interesting so so
graphs are
indeed a very good use case of these
restrictive computational domains i
guess
um do you see other obvious examples
yeah anytime you have a program where
you have lots of python objects floating
around
and it seems to be getting slow and you
seem to be using a lot of memory
that's a restricted computation i mean
put it put a little manager class around
it and then
put enough restrictions do some kind of
boxing and unboxing on the inside you
know to pull things in and out of the
computational domain
and then as necessary ad optimizations
makes a lot of sense i i think it's it's
a general pattern now obviously what
you'll probably do in practice
is you're probably your manager class
will probably just use a pandas data
frame or a numpy nd array so itself will
just make use of an existing one
and that's what i see as a very common
pattern you have you know individual
items representing the business entities
and then you decide i'll put them in a
manager class i'll have the manager
class using the numpy and array the
pandas data frame
the user of your code doesn't really
know that the backend is a pandas data
frame or an pind array
they just see the individual entities
that are boxed and unboxed and they just
get some aggregate operations
that makes sense um one of the questions
from
chat was about the map filter example
with the with the tag decorator
what the what the trade-off is there by
writing it sort of in that push-down way
versus
the straightforward way
the example itself is somewhat synthetic
and so what makes it somewhat synthetic
is
you're assuming that you're able to do
this kind of predator push down
a predicate push-on is a very common
thing that you see in sql query
optimizers
but it does require quite a bit of
structural information there is some
sleight of hand there in that you can't
really swap the map
in the filter unless you know for
certain that that's correct and you need
quite a bit of information added to the
program in order to be able to make sure
that's correct
so in this example i just kind of struck
my shoulders and say look imagine that
you have that information
imagine you can add that in because it's
not too hard to add that in
now in terms of disadvantages that
approach i don't know that i could
really come up with a specific
disadvantage
fundamentally it's just a different
approach for writing code instead of
writing them as composition of functions
which no longer give you enough
information about what's happening at
runtime you write them as generators
now i wrote this example and i shared it
with tom caswell from matplotlib
and i shared it with him
a couple weeks ago because this came up
when i was doing a python training
and uh you know i threw some code
together i thought this is pretty cool
so i showed it to tom
and tom shared with us that in his work
at brookhaven national lab on nsl2
they've actually built a generator
framework very similar to this
and so while i haven't seen many
approaches like this in practice
it is the case that people are doing
things like this and so it might be
useful at some point to get tom
or dan allen from brookhaven to talk
about the generator framework they've
built because they've built
a very similar framework for
representing the the
experiments that their scientists are
doing on the laser and then performing
some kind of optimizations on that
experimental flow
that's really cool do you know whether
that's open source store
uh brookhaven is an open site so none of
the work they do i think is classified
so i don't know if the code itself is
open
but i don't think there's any
restrictions for him to talk about it
let's talk about it
okay that's a that's a good one
definitely reach out to intent
sounds pretty interesting cool
um i don't think there's any other
questions
from from chat or q a as far as i can
see
um so yeah well thank you again for uh
for this talk it was it was really nice
thank you thank you thank you everyone
thank you mathias and marissa for
putting this
event on really appreciate you putting
in the hard work to make this possible
yeah you're welcome um these these kinds
of things make it uh make it worth it so
uh
glad to have done so all right
um well with that i i'd like to uh to
say goodbye and see uh well see you next
time james at
the next virtual pi data event i guess
must be a bit easier to
attend them all this year than last year
yeah
it might be so i'll see you all at pi
day global thank you everybody
thanks and uh thank you to all the
attendees hope to see you again either
during the lunch session or this
evening's talk session
all right thanks everyone i'll stick
around for a couple minutes in the
discord if you have any other questions
otherwise it was a pleasure
really my pleasure speaking with you and
i hope you enjoyed this presentation
thanks everyone
awesome thanks